what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here so I am running late to go to movie
fights but that episode should be up by
now at the time this video is up I had
to check this out I can't really talk
about it it's the gameplay trailer for
Red Dead Redemption - I've recently beat
Red Dead Redemption the first one maybe
like two weeks ago or something like
that I really loved the hell out of it
spoilers if you haven't played it hated
the ending a little bit what happened
with John Marston Joe and Morstan when
he died hat just was like went through
all that [ __ ] just for this end it was
really upsetting anyway I think the
cameras crooked no time to adjust it
let's watch this the graphics look
better America was evolving on its way
to the most powerful country in the
world
new immigrants arrived thriving outpost
became towns and civilization was
spreading rapidly into the huge wild and
lawless frontier with Red Dead
Redemption - Rockstar Games aims to
create a living world simply open bar
fight storytelling in a notorious gang
that's cool you get it be an outlaw this
time in the game awesome I like it I
like it
the game is an attempt to capture this
pivotal moment when the age of outlaws
was ending and the modern world was born
Wow there is a huge world to explore sat
across a range of America's heartland
and frontier
from harsh mountain trails and dense
forests to untain swamp lands and all
populated with a diverse cast of
characters from turn-of-the-century life
now shoo I'm waiting for someone
you play as Arthur Morgan a trusted
senior gun and vanderlin
[Music]
[Music]
they play is John Marston skip each time
they're forced to flee an area the gang
sets up a camp at the base this is where
gang members eat sleep perform chores
play games and share stories these are
the people Arthur calls family and you
will get to know each gang member over
the course of the game really helping
the camp with food and supplies will
keep morale high while spending time
with other gang members can reveal new
secrets fun things to do and
opportunities for miss Joe
go and redistribute some property in and
out of camp the world is alive and
responds to the player and your guns are
the only way to interact with the
environment call out to a passing rider
talk yourself into trouble with a local
tough guy or out of trouble with a town
sheriff
or intimidate a witness into silence and
more you can form friendships or make
enemies as you choose your actions have
consequences and it's up to you to
decide just how honorable Arthur is
should you Jimmy Brooks shooting and
fighting have both been radically
improved to make combat deep
and engaging at all times and I smell
it's so much better interesting with
realistic reload and recoiled it always
keeps the player grounded and connected
to the action in a gunfight in a similar
way to bond with your horse is crucial
and changes based on your treatment of
the animal oh cool some breeds you're
better suited for certain tasks seems
like you have to really form
relationships in this game we're of
course like this for a while your saddle
and saddle bags can store extra weapons
along with supplies and animal carcasses
that you pick up while out roaming or
hunting over time the bond between you
and your horse will grow making them
easier to control in tense situations a
rich and varied ecosystem thrives in the
world and sometimes deadly you wanna
come with me hunting helps the camp or
earns you money wounded animal and
you'll have to track them down
animal balance
other items you find can be treated for
cash to use at general stores gunsmiths
saloons and elsewhere this is God's own
country and I feel I'm in purgatory this
is a world that is rich in depth and
detail hi I can't argue that no to be
explored on horseback or on foot as you
live the fateful journey of a gang of
Outlaws on the run across America
[Music]
in the next gameplay video using the
Deadeye system father effort okay so I
can only talk for like one minute right
now but I love this so far this just
seems like what you know they're saying
here it's just a more finely tuned
detailed version of what we got would
Red Dead Redemption won everything from
the fighting the gunplay and every
relationship you form even if it's with
a horse affects the gameplay I love
those real details make you feel a part
of the world I thought you were gonna
play as John marcin's kid because of the
way how the first game ended I just
assumed that's where we would be going I
hope he at least gets to be a character
in this game I would hate that actually
if he doesn't even show up I haven't
done any research on Red Dead Redemption
ii haven't seen any other trailers so
hopefully he at least shows up once you
guys put it in the comments let me know
if he does anyway like in the first one
when I heard about Red Dead Redemption
you're living in the West I thought like
oh you're gonna be a criminal and do
criminal things and you know you do get
to do that but I love the setup here
where you're part of a gang you get to
know the gang members you get a know the
outlaws of you get a really be an outlaw
not an outlaw who's trying to do good
and get his family back which is a good
story but I feel like you're gonna be
able to be in the nitty-gritty of the
you know kind of like the Western world
of the movies that I grew up on so this
is a lot more of what I actually wanted
Red Dead Redemption to be granted I love
the first game but this is even just
this is a lot more of what I want right
now it feels like a fully realized
Western world I like the time frame and
when it's taking place the outlaws are
dying out the different environments are
gonna be able to go through like I love
when they're going through snow and
there's like a snowstorm going on and
all those details of being in the forest
the animals even look more to find
everything just looks so much more
richly defined the only thing missing
for me in the first Red Dead Redemption
was just some finer tuned graphics in
this game is
giving me that and you got to be a
hardcore criminal here I'm excited for
this man I can't wait to pick it up and
play it the gameplay doesn't really
tease the music but that was one of my
favorite things about the first game too
was how awesome the music was in that
game so I hope you get some cool western
music style here as well yeah I don't
have time really for my thoughts
together I got to get going but hey
check out my movie fights episode I
don't know if I did a good job or not I
won the last time I was on maybe I did
alright this time let's you know go and
find out anyway guys you can subscribe
to the region he should click that
notification about check us out page
around full-length TV show reactions
weekly Q&A and music video coverage we'd
love to have you become a patronage act
today